and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Star Trek
33.1 bite - I have just eat my greatest
movie I've ever seen in my life
there's this guy called Kirk and his
father was build up by aliens because of
this he grows up to be an asshole
asshole who likes to make out with green
women I made out with a green woman once
only she was a liar
she wasn't green oh she was turquoise it
this is pointy here guy cause fuck
asshole - but to be fair everybody his
race is an asshole they want him to join
the international legal point here guys
and they're like you did well just fight
the disadvantage of being a human
everything is like you know what screw
you guys I'm going to blow its subject
and it's like asshole track to boldly go
where no asshole has gone before
that reminds me what's the difference
between the Starship Enterprise and
toilet paper people certainly Uranus and
look for Klingons but I digress
and encourage is like what's your first
name
ruins like me sounds French so they all
go to Starfleet Academy
which is a wonderful place they believe
in Kaplan education it's a good
discussions logical reasoning and if I
read Universal Federation of course I
guess in the future women's rights takes
a huge step backwards we'll miss you
have a very impressive record
unfortunately your legs up lemme next
show me go into outer space just not the
evil run units I don't get why everybody
says Romulans are so evil everything's
bush get out of office it hasn't been so
bad but we did Republicans so the
Romulan Republicans are looking for
Spock but not the new Spock yields back
played by Leonard Nimrod in there
because he accidentally destroyed a
planet I just joined a planet once It
was as if a million voices cried out and
there was suddenly silence it was so
cool so the old spot talks to the young
seaman says I travel back in time and
now there's a parallel dimension so if
you guys were to say grow up differently
or different circumstances that we could
write and create happened and it makes
sense I use writers die did you take
that obsessive fan base wait you're
right anything we want now we can turn
Captain Kirk into a doctor you have
accept it and do that'd be pretty cool
doc Trek whoa the Romulan Republicans
have this evil power that kind of looks
like both those knows I don't know all
those knows was an evil power though
they often say nectar it's a great
weapon but not a weapon of mass
destruction so things are blowing up in
the ships are flying everywhere and Kirk
is like to take us out of you
and Sulu is like for you I'm going to
White Castle the cooler for any writer
I'm doing watching spot make out with
the hurrah
that's right spot makes out with the
hora he is one horny Balkan and he's
like I shall only go where no one has
gone before
they play the famous Star Trek unlike
their fans this is Jerry Busey money so
I can see the scene 1 star trek to Sulu
and check out go to my Catherine